[Musique]
dans le cadre des Jeux Olympiques
beaucoup de gares vont être réaménagé
dans cet objectif PMR bien que n'étant
pas une une une ville avec des sites
olympiques nous avons uniquement un site
d'entraînement nous avons souhaité nous
avons agi de manière à ce que cette cas
cette gare soit totalement
réhabilitée il va y avoir de nouveaux de
nouveaux ascenseurs il va y avoir des
rallongements de ca il va il va y avoir
des des dalles podotactiles il va y
avoir une remise à niveau de tout ce qui
est éclairage il va y avoir à
l'intérieur une accessibilité aussi au
niveau des guichets et puis à
l'extérieur il va y avoir des une une
sortie qui n'était pas
[Musique]
prévu lorsque nous avons fait notre
première réunion avec la SNCF il nous a
été affirmé nous serons très vigilants à
contrôler cela que le le bruit sera très
très très réduit il va y avoir des
travaux qui vont durer la nuit de
manière à essayer de perturber le moins
possible la l'ensemble des habitants que
ce soit les habitants de ce côté de si
de la gare ou de ou de l'autre côté avec
une une une plage horaire de
0h30 du matin jusqu'à jusqu'à 4h30 plus
un certain nombre de de weekends qu'on
déjà étaé planifié un minimum de 8
[Musique]
weekends